ich bitte ich meld dich lass uns reden
du kannst dich auch bei mir melden oder
du weißt hier rechtenstein hat euch
aufgenommen und jetzt für alle
willkommen und wenn du hilfe brauchst
oder einfach reden willst melde ich
wünschte das beste für dich und ich
wünsche ganz sagt dass du lebst und dass
du
und wunderschönes leben hast und wie
gesagt
melde dich doch
verzweifelte worte vernahm anis
nachhilfelehrerin beatrice fernandes sie
hatte sich in den letzten jahren um die
vermisste teenagerinnen und ihre familie
gekümmert
rückblende ein unbeschwerter ein
glücklicher moment armani alia fall in
ihrem klassenraum sie lacht mit einer
freundin strahlt armani das mädchen das
mit ihrer familie 2017 aus der hölle des
syrischen bürgerkriegs in aleppo nach
baden württemberg flow ist in
deutschland angekommen doch seit 26 juni
frühmorgens ist sie spurlos verschwunden
sie ist am 26
juli morgens noch von rechtenstein wo
die familie wohnt nach ehingen mit dem
bus gefahren ist dort am bahnhof noch
gesehen worden wie sie aus dem bus
ausstieg und in richtung war ihr straße
gegen das ist die richtung wo auch ihre
schule ist
und unterwegs wurde sie dann gegen 7.20
noch mal gesehen im bereich von zwei
straßen am ramminger heißt eine davon
und dort in diesem bereich haben zeugen
sie noch mal bemerkt ihren grauen
schulrucksack mit den schwarzen punkten
findet eine spaziergängerin ganz in der
nähe der magdalena neff schule in
ehingen in einem wäldchen die polizei
hat die fundstelle auf dem waldboden
drei meter von einem pfad entfernten mit
roter farbe markiert wurde armani
verschleppt auffällig in ihrer
schultasche fand die polizei handy
geldbeutel und schulsachen seither wird
unermüdlich nach der jungen frau gesucht
angehörige und freunde des mädchens
werde befragt bislang erfolglos
ich habe in dem moment als gab das
angebracht ist oder ich konnte etwas
überhaupt nicht erklären wir wollen mit
amys vater sprechen aber die familie
lehnt ab
freunde von armani zeigen uns dieses
instagram profil hier lebt amani
offenbar eine fantasie aus gibt sich als
mädchen aus korea aus zeitmangel bilder
und liebes postings mit einer internet
liebe hier ist auf arabisch zu lesen du
schöne wie viel wahrheit wie viel wunsch
und fantasie in diesem posting steckt
unklar
wo steckt amalia fall für ihre
nachhilfelehrerin gibt es zwei
möglichkeiten zwei sachen entweder hat
der vater die chance genutzt um sie zu
entführen und zu verheiraten oder armani
hat es geschickt geplant dass sie dann
gehen konnte werden ihren weg gehen
konnte die fahndung nach armani läuft
die polizei hat im vermisstenfall
folgende fragen ja für uns ist es
zunächst einmal ganz wichtig zu sehen ob
es jemanden gibt der etwas verdächtiges
beobachtet hat gerade in der nähe dieser
straße am rande internet des
berufsschulzentrums wir fragen natürlich
nach etwaigen videoaufnahmen wenn jemand
zum beispiel mit einer kamera mit einer
dash cam mit dem handy im bereich des
bahnhofs ehingen oder gewerblichen
schule an diesem 26 juli aufnahmen
gemacht hat das könnte für uns wichtig
sein wir suchen personen die zuletzt
kontakt hatten mit der familie der
armani vielleicht weiß jemand auch eine
kontaktperson von armani sonst niemand
kennt das sind dinge die uns natürlich
brennend interessieren aber auch andere
hinweise jeder noch so kleine hinweis
kann für uns wichtig sein
[Musik]